n
légalement responsable.
Andréanne Williams.
- Women, Life, Freedom!
- C'est un bien triste
veveversaire qu'ont célébré
les familles des victimes
de l'écrasement du vol PS752.
En janvier 2020, l'avion a été
atatattu, quelques minutes
seulement après avoir décollé
de l'aéroport de Téhéran,
par deux missiles lancés
par des membres du Corps
des gardiens de la révolution
islamique de l'Iran.
85 Canadiens et résidents
permanents ont perdu la vie.
Plus de 1000 jours plus tard,
leurs familles attendent
toujours que justice soit faite.
ARMIN MORATTAB
proche de victimes
- Ça doit être beaucoup de force
de la part du gouvernement
du Canada d'aller forcer
le régime iranien
pour avoir la vérité.
- Armin Morattab a perdu
son frère jumeau et sa belle-
dadadadadans la tragédie.
Et malgré le temps
qui passe, la douleur
est toujours aussi vive.
- On a eupupupupup
de beaux moments ensemble.
Notre vie a changé beaucoup.
- Dans son discours, le premier
ministre Justin Trudeau s'est
engagé à faire en sorte que
la république islamique rende
des comptes pour l'écrasement
du vol PS752.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU
premier ministre du Canada
- On va continuer d'être là
pour demander des comptes
au régime iranien.
- Une promesse que cette célèbre
journaliste et militante
iranienne en exihohohohohorté
à tenir.
"Nous avons besoin de votre
action", le e e e e e lancé.
En décembre, le Canada,
la Suède, l'Ukraine
et le Royaume-Uni ont déclenché
un processus officiel pour tenir
l'Iran légalement responsable
de l'écrasement du Boeing.
ntntntntntnt que l'Iran
se soumette à un arbitrage
contraignant pour que
la république islamique soit
tenue légalement responsablea as
ne s'accordent pas sur
l'organisation de l'arbitrage
au cours des six prochains mois,
Ottawa s'adressera à la Cour
internationale de justice.
"Nous mettons en oeuvre
toutes nos options, sans compter
les sanctions que nous avons
annoncéetrtrtrtrtrtrtre
des personnes responsables
de la destruction de l'avion",
assure le ministre fédéral
des Transports.
n'n'n'n'n'n'n'a pas confiance
en le régime iranien, Armin
Morattab garde espoir.
Il espère que le soulèvement
populaire de son peuple en Iran
au cours des derniers mois fera
tomber le régime iranien,lalala,
que justice soit faite.
Ici Andréane Williams,
Radio-Canada, Toronto